[Music]
foreign
a few days ago a tweet from my Hollywood
Insider about Spider-Man across the
spider-verse began circulating on social
media the reliable informant big screen
leaks commented on whether the second
spider-verse movie will be better than
its predecessor the response was a clear
yes which further increased the
excitement among fans for the sequel due
for release in the summer in addition to
this pleasant but not very significant
information some exclusive images were
released this week via Empire magazine
the first image shows the colorful
mumbatin Universe protected by the
Indian Spider-Man pavateer prabhakar
moreover on a cover we can see the
skyline of mubaton which will play an
important role in the upcoming film
another image shows the popular
Spider-Man 2099 in battle with the
villain vulture the antagonist is best
known for his appearance in Spider-Man
Homecoming in which he was embodied by
Michael Keaton and had to face Tom
Holland Spider-Man a while later Empire
followed up with an image of main
character Miles Morales and his
girlfriend Gwen Stacy AKA spiderweb two
can be seen hanging out on a house
facade the idea is to tie in with the
events of the first part and at the same
time set the stage for the subsequent
film Spider-Man beyond the spider-verse
together miles and other Spider-Man
companions will travel through several
universes to protect the Earth from a
new Mighty villain in order to achieve
this the team plans to go the extra mile
visually by using six different
animation Styles in the film however the
focus is not only on the visuals
Spider-Man across the spider-verse is
also intended to address the fans
emotionally as screenwriter and producer
Christopher Miller recently revealed in
an interview we are definitely excited
and can't wait for the movie to be
released on June 2nd 2023
[Music]
thank you